so you finally got your guitar it's all
tuned up and you're ready to go you're
ready to learn your first song right
well maybe so before you start actually
playing it your guitar which you might
be feeling you know can we get going
already you want to learn a few things
about how to actually practice your
guitar because everyone knows practice
is important you know if you're a
musician you have to put in the hours
otherwise we're not going to get good
but just as important as how much you
practice is how you actually do the
practice okay a lot of people say
practice makes perfect and that's sort
of true
practice makes habit if you do something
over and over again you're training your
mind and your body to do that same thing
over and over again and that's just
music that's everything in life and so
therefore you know it doesn't take too
much logic to realize if you don't
practice well the thing that you will
learn is whatever you're practicing
whether it's good or not so practice
doesn't make perfect practice makes
habit I think what people mean when they
say that is good practice it makes
perfect so you want to make sure that
the time and the hours are you're going
to put in is actually going to be
valuable to your productive and will
make you a better guitarist so here are
a few tips on how to practice your
guitar well first thing don't practice
too long I know you start off thinking
okay I have to put in lots and lots of
hours and overtime that's true but I
would recommend no more than kind of
well I think the ideal length is kind of
15 to 20 minutes if you want to practice
longer than that then do 15 to 20
minutes and then have a break and let
you or your fingers and your mind and
your body relax for a little while maybe
take 15 to 20 minutes away and then come
back and practice again the reason why
is if you practice a long time like say
you practice an hour or two hours just
consecutively okay particularly at the
beginning for instance if your fingers
just aren't strong enough okay over the
time of your practice session your
fingers will get more and more tired and
as you get tired your technique will
deteriorate and your concentration will
deteriorate and as a result what you end
up practice
with your fingers and your mind won't be
that good quality so you know if you're
practicing for say 60 minutes your first
20 minutes I will probably be valuable
to you and you'll learn some your hands
and your brain will learn some helpful
patterns but like minutes you know 40 to
60 most people will be too tired and
that actually would be adding much to
you as a player okay so practice in
short bursts and do that frequently you
know think about how people learn things
like how to tie their shoelaces okay
usually it's not the case that someone
says you know today's the day I'm gonna
spend four hours practicing to tie my
shoelaces right and then after that I
get it down pat you know rather than
that kind of lengthy drawn-out
once upon a time once for all kind of
practice session how do we learn to tie
our shoelaces well we do it you know
once twice and then we do it every day
twice a day maybe and the the repetition
over time is what develops that
technique and it becomes second nature
okay so that's the kind of practice you
want to have with a musical instrument
as well
secondly you want to sit properly now
often you know all the focus is on the
guitar but we like you know and how you
hold it and where you're pressing and
all that kind of thing but your body our
body's a set of muscles they're all
connected together right so what you're
doing up here and you know down here it
all connects to how your your arms and
your hands are going to function to play
the guitar okay so see probably I'd
recommend sitting on an actual chair
rather on a bed cross-legged you want to
sit up straight not like you know oh
someone's watching me and I have to be
really upright but in a way that is I'm
relaxed even though you know at the
beginning you try to watch what's
happening on the guitar and you're
actually constantly hunching over to
look at what your fingers are doing
because it's not a second nature yet but
after you do that you don't want to play
in this kind of hunched over position
it's really really awkward it's a bad
pattern to set so as much as possible
you should be sitting relatively up
straight if you need to look go ahead
and do that and then go back to a more
relaxed position the reason why you want
try and get your whole body in the right
position is that tension in any part of
your body will translate to tension in
your fingers and that will ruin your
playing okay so if your shoulders are
tense or if your back is tense or if
you're hunched over all of that's going
to translate through your arms into your
hands into your fingers and it'll have
an effect on how you're playing it's not
a good one so you want to be as relaxed
as possible whenever you're playing and
whenever you're practicing therefore
okay thirdly and this is a really really
really important one and it goes against
you know most people's instincts when
they're trying to play a guitar like
like most people when I first started
playing I had a particular song that I
wanted to learn how to play and I was
like yeah this is what I'm picking up
the guitar right and so you know put on
the CD and figure out what chords Osment
to play and then I would try and play
along with the with the song on the CD
which is insane because you're trying to
learn all of these changes and do it at
the speed that the song is playing right
and you know they might be very very you
not very not maybe if they're on a CD
they're gonna be very very good
musicians and so you know they can do
all sorts of crazy fast changes which as
a beginner you're not ready to do so
practice slowly and what I mean by that
is you know for instance suppose the
song you're playing you have a a G chord
that goes into a D chord that goes into
an E minor okay that that's that chord
progression who will play 90% of western
music so how do you go about practicing
that well you want to rather than try to
match the chord changes to the speed of
song you want to think okay what's my
first chord you know all your fingers in
the right spot be relaxed have as little
tension in your body as possible and
then think well what's the next chord
that I'm moving to okay now think about
what that position is and then literally
move one finger at a time to practice
that transition so I would think okay
the main fingers I'm going to need
well instead of these three figures I'm
going to use these three figures so I'm
going to let go of my little finger I'm
gonna think about what's my next
movement
I want my middle figure to come down to
the top Easter Egg so I'm gonna move
that down and then I think okay what's
next well my index finger can pop in
there and that leaves a spot for my ring
finger and now I'm in position for the
next chord and then I'll repeat that
process again when I think about okay
where these fingers gonna go okay now
that process obviously if I was actually
playing the song I've totally missed it
right but the important thing is when
I'm actually playing it at proper speed
you know I want to make sure that my
movements are as efficient as possible
right that I'm not moving extra distance
or I'm not moving my fingers in a weird
convoluted way to get to the core that
I'm I want to get to right so in order
to get that movement right the
efficiency you have to practice them
really slowly
so that you have the right path that
speed comes later you can add speed in
later and that's that's you know will
come in due time but you want to
practice slowly and get it right that's
important just like we said you know
it's not practice makes perfect
it's the right practice makes perfect so
if it's particularly if it's an unusual
chord change I remember there was a song
I was trying to learn which went from E
minor to a b7 which is just an uncommon
chord in itself so I had to use all four
fingers and I just wasn't used to
getting my fingers in this position so
what I did was for my 15 to 20 minutes I
would just practice going from that
chord to that next chord and I'll just
do that over and over again back to the
E minor and even though it doesn't sound
very good and it you know in the song it
moves on to some other chord later I
need to get this change down and develop
it slowly before I could get the rest of
this song down okay and that speed comes
later and just following on from that
fourthly when you're practicing practice
single skills or single movements or
single progressions break it down into
little chunks so if you've if you're
picking up a song for the first time
it might have anything from you know
four to five you know a normal song I
have four to five different progressions
of chords and obviously there's
something out there that might have 10
or 11 but that's that's not as common
now what you want to do if you're
starting out you want to say look to
play this whole song I need to learn
these five progressions okay there's the
GD e minor there's the E minor v7 a mine
or something like that okay and I'll
need to learn all of these five to play
the whole song but in one 15 to 20
minute block of practice you just want
to work on one of those sets of
transitions one set of three or four
chords in a row and then just do that
over and over again okay the reason why
is that your brain is trying to wrap its
mind around this new process that you're
putting your body through right and the
more repetition in a row that you'll get
the more you'll you'll sort of
consolidate that skill rather than if
you if you race through and you're
learning say five different progressions
which might be twenty chords you know in
whatever order they're in it's really
hard to learn what the first you know
the first ten are let alone get the the
whole twenty right
I oughta think about it this way if
you're memorizing say an essay right how
long's an essay like two to three
thousand words maybe okay you're gonna
be in for it if all you do is you start
from word one and you go all the way up
to where two thousand he's read it all
the way through and think okay how much
of that do I remember by the time you
get to the 2000s word you've already
forgotten the way it started right far
better to say okay let's just take a
small chunk I can memorize a sentence
ten words okay um let's just memorize my
opening sentence I can get that down in
you know say ten to fifteen minutes okay
and then you've got one section you can
move on to the next one
okay so practice single skills it might
be just like I have with that a minor b7
it might just be moving from one chord
to another right often that's the way it
is we say Barre chords which we'll talk
about later but you know say a C
to a b-minor the way I played my see
this is a C with the G base which I'll
talk about another time I'm using four
fingers for this chord and I'm using
four fingers for the next corner so
there's a lot of movement going on right
so in order to practice that progression
now I'm going to go play that card and
they look at each individual finger to
think about where each one's going to
move and we're gonna take that shape
down and then fall back so I'm gonna do
that movement over and over again until
I feel comfortable with doing it at
speed and being able doing without
watching it and that's the point in
which you don't okay I'm comfortable I
think I could move on to something else
so practice single skills or single
movements lastly be really careful about
the position of your fingers okay
now it'll help if you have if if no one
else has ever taught you how to do play
the guitar it's really helpful to have
either I don't watch you know someone
else use which is very skilled and doing
this and watch the way that their
fingers move and there's lots of
different valid ways to to place your
fingers but some are better than others
okay so I'll give you an example a lot
of guitars out there for instance if
they're playing a a D okay so this is
this is a normal way to play a D their
thumb will come around like this okay
and that's the way that they play it now
remember that when you're playing
streams the whole idea is to hold the
strings at the right frets down firmly
and if you don't hold them firmly enough
you don't particularly at the beginning
where your fingers aren't that strong
and the strings will bias or they just
weren't they won't make the right sound
because your fingers are actually
holding the strings enough to mute the
strings and make them not make sound not
holding them enough to actually let them
read yeah okay now if I've got my thumb
all the way up here okay think about how
I'm holding those strings down what
muscles am i using in my hand and the
the kinds of muscles I'm using on these
three figures and then are kind of
pushing against the back of the
fretboard with kind of this this whole
section of my palm here okay which is
actually a really inefficient way to do
it because the strongest muscle that I
have
my in my hand is the one that drives my
phone okay so it's not pushing from here
I'd rather push from this big muscle
through my thumb okay so a better way to
play the D is to actually have my thumb
nice down low here okay so you can see
you actually will not be able to see my
thumb probably from the front camera
okay but if you have a look around you
can see that it's it's nice down below
in fact it's a directly opposite as much
as possible the actual figures that are
Freddie okay so there's one thing the
position of your thumb vitally important
I mean sometimes it'll creep up
especially if you're standing up playing
because you have to kind of keep the
whole neck of the guitar from moving
around and and that will happen
naturally but try and position your
thumb at the back of the of the neck
that's a really easy area to make let
your thumb creep over the top secondly
with your fingers you want to make sure
that your fingers are pushing as close
as possible to perpendicular to the
fretboard okay because that way you'll
get the maximum amount of force falling
down the strings so you don't have to
press his heart in order to keep the
strings down okay
so you want to play like this as opposed
to kind of add an angle like this where
if you think about if you actually get
your guitar out and you play it like
this you'll see that more of your finger
has to press down onto the guitar so you
got to press harder in order to put the
same amount of force okay now why do a
lot of people play like this where their
fingers angled across the fretboard
rather than pointing into the fretboard
and the reason tends to be that people
have long fingernails okay so my
fingernails are pretty short because
I've been playing guitar for a long time
and the reasons to have short
fingernails but you can see that if I
had long fingernails they'd get in the
way of where my fingertips are gonna
hold the strings down okay now I know a
lot of people out there particularly
women I'm not going to be that keen on
having very short fingernails and they
don't have to be as short as mine but
basically if you can feel your
fingernails stopping you from pushing on
to the frets of the guitar that's an
indicator that it's gonna
your play you still play but it'll be
harder for you to play quickly and to
get the strings down nice and firmly and
not have any new buzzy when you're
holding the strings down so don't
practice too long
make sure you sit properly in a relaxed
but upright way I take your time when
you're practicing and going through the
motions so the movements that you want
to practice practice them slowly
practice a single skill at a time and
then you can move on to bigger things
and I'll be very careful with the
positions of your fingers and think
through what they're doing so that you
can play with the maximum efficiency and
you know not have to put as much more
strength into it than you have to